let's continue speaking to folks via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go
next to
jonah from st louis jonah you're on the
air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey david yeah uh so
i was
watching a previous episode and you were
making comment about
uh how
more republicans don't come out against
trump
um you know i think you were referring
to paul ryan at the time
and your reason was if paul ryan was
running for office he wouldn't have the
courage to do so
um but i think you know we have a couple
of really good examples of
politicians doing that in this chain
and um
and liz cheney and adam kinzinger
yes there's no question so i don't
remember if i said he he wouldn't i mean
i i definitely said he doesn't have to
worry because he's not running i i'm not
saying he definitely wouldn't if he were
running for something but it's just that
he's not running for anything right now
and right now he's free to say whatever
but you're right i mean kenzinger
mitt romney there are liz cheney there
are people it's it's not even always
that they're coming out against trump
they're just sort of telling some truth
that the trumpists are unwilling to hear
like joe biden really won but i think
it's certainly easier when you're not
running for anything to just speak your
mind
yeah i totally agree with that i guess
my point is that um i think in another
episode um you know you were you were
sort of downplaying
um what cheney and kinzinger were doing
you know and and you know i guess uh
highlighting what
what their downsides are more than than
what you know what they're currently
doing to speak up against
you know trumpism yeah um and you know
i'm wondering if that's a missed
opportunity to kind of make better
examples of what's going on there and
then you know making it a safer place
right for for people like them to do
that no but here's the thing you have to
remember
the
liz cheney
told the truth that joe biden really won
liz cheney still voted with trump's
position 90 of the time so it's not that
i was downplaying the point was
this party has become so perverted that
just stating who won the election is
considered dissent and that's crazy but
at the end of the day these are not my
friends as a progressive because they
still agree with trump on just about
everything it wasn't about down playing
or up playing it was just about
explaining on policy these are not
people i agree with
yeah yeah no i get that i guess it's uh
i guess the little wind strategy right
take what you can get and
you know just climb it the the problem
is
how much are we gonna give them an atta
boy just for acknowledging who won the
election like yes compared to many of
their cohorts
they're they're doing something that's
different but it shouldn't be something
you get a it's sort of like when parents
use food as a reward and they're like
you know if you eat your veggies then
we'll give you a pound of ice cream and
it's like no no like
you just you get veggies are part of the
meal you should you don't want to use it
as a you don't want to start using as a
reward something that should just be hey
we eat a balanced diet in this house and
it's sort of the same idea like how much
are we going to really praise them just
for telling us who won the election uh i
get why but let's not go overboard
yeah make sense i appreciate it my
pleasure yeah thanks for calling in
there's jonah from st louis
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read you have to check out
one of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
non-fiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it i recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great stephen hawking this is a
book that i have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video